[Music]
people can often think about meditation
as
something like a grim duty all right
i've got to go to therapy and i've got
to work out and i've got a diet and i
should meditate as you know as if it's
some self-help thing and especially
since you asked you know when your
nervous system is all of ours is in
disarray right now somewhat and vigilant
and wary
meditation is is not supposed to be a
grim duty but rather
more an act of adventure and
understanding of opening the mind and
heart
and bringing a sense of well-being
mahatma gandhi said
what uses freedom
if it doesn't also include the freedom
to make mistakes
and my teacher ajah we would ask him
different questions about things and a
lot of the times he would say it's
uncertain isn't it
you know tell me about enlightenment
he'd smile he'd say it's uncertain isn't
it well tell me what happens when you
die it's uncertain isn't it i mean he
had teachings
but he loved the wisdom of uncertainty
of our he said why don't you be just as
you talked about him
when you're washing the dishes
as tiknot han described to feel the
soapy water in your hands and enjoy
washing the dishes or being with another
person
i remember reading about these russian
astronauts who got in trouble
and were
not sure they would even make it back
from their orbit above the earth where
they've been for a while but finally
they did and their capsule came down and
opened and they said they touched the
earth with their feet and it was the
most glorious moment just to be in the
dusty plain of kazakhstan and
the ground and the plants that people
might have called weeds
to see the eyes of people who were
walking around beating them or to be
able to go home
and sit at a table with people felt
absolutely miraculous
and so there's something about
meditation
when we quiet the mind and yes we can
bring compassion and tend to all the
difficulties that we carry
but it's an invitation to get bigger
to feel the sense of mystery
as the poet says i'm moving at
tremendous speed toward a star in the
milky way
my heart's a little fast
otherwise everything is fine
and for you and those who listen
to remember that spirit of adventure
and joy that was there
as a child the child of the spirit so if
you would tim
close your eyes for a moment let's just
meditate together and other people can
join us
and take a couple of long breaths and
let yourself settle
and notice that there are different
channels consciousness has these
different dimensions and you can tune
into the channel of despair or the one
of outrage
but you can also tune into the channel
of the dalai lama and tutu and so forth
of adventure and caring and joy
as you sit quietly
let yourself remember
one of the best moments of your
childhood
even vaguely one of the best days of
joy laughing playing
enjoying tickling the child of the
spirit
and keeping your eyes closed feel it and
let me know if you can remember
something like that
i can
and what's it feel like in your body
stay with it
it feels light unencumbered
feels
expansive
exploratory
beautiful beautiful
so stay with this the quality of light
and unencumbered
expansive exploratory joyful
and let it fill your body
and let it fill your cells in dna
to remind you that this
child of the spirit this inviolable joy
that was born into you is still really
available
it can't be taken from you no matter
what
so just let it open and
feel it filling your
whole being
in a easy
joyful way
and now let yourself imagine
that some being
who carries the spirit of joy and wisdom
amidst everything in human life
some amazing being
comes to join you
you know as a
as a guide it's a
friend
as a
inspiration
and let yourself be surprised who wants
to become this carrier of joy and
wisdom amidst it all
and see who wants to arrive or appear
and allowing this keeping your eyes
closed notice let me know who if anyone
comes
well it's actually a friend of mine is
younger than i am
who i think does a pretty good job
with levity good good good good
and adventure
while also being really effective in the
world
so both adventurous and joyful
adventurous and effective
and so this friend
a male female
male in this case
this guy this fellow comes
and he's there with you and you see his
smile and maybe he puts his arm around
your shoulder he's like your brother
we're in this together
come on let's have a good time
let's make an adventure where we make a
difference
and we do it with real joy
and let yourself feel that connection so
that
you're together in this
we need that from one another
and then as you feel this he reaches
into his pocket
and he has a gift for you
that's a clear symbol of what you need
to step out of that
small sense of self that you've talked
about that's
vigilant hyper vigilant
and you know learn to try to protect
yourself
but you know he knows you're much bigger
than that
and he has a the perfect symbol the gift
that will help you
to be who you really are
this joyful vast adventurous spirit
and see what he gives to you
he places it in your hands if it's not
clear you can lift it up to the to the
light so you can see it
just what you need
what do you get from him
would you like my answer
yeah
so i don't know why well there maybe
there is no why but
it looks like a very
small maybe
inch
and a quarter inch and a half
diameter almost like a pendant but it's
a
silver circle with some type of circular
bluish green stone in the center which
is round
all right so hold it in your hand
and then you can ask him what does this
symbolize and he'll tell you
you can know
your intuition your understanding will
come
but what does he tell you it symbolizes
uh
unending
connection the circularity of it yes the
illusion of separateness
[Music]
so hold it in your hand and he's
reminding you that part of the joy
and the adventure you can have is that
you're connected with it all you're
always connected
that circularity and there's a joy in
that a spirit you can't fall out of that
circle because it is you
you are life
and then he whispers in your ear a few
words of support for living with joy
what does he say
the first thing he came to mind was take
it easy
listen to that i've heard the song
myself
you know and and you're laughing as you
say it and feel that laughter fill your
body
because he's really reminding you who
you are
that you can do this that this is
actually not just a channel but this is
underneath all the rest that we try to
do here we are we try to be
grown-ups responsible protect ourselves
take care of everything
take it easy you can do what you do as
he does
adventure and
success with this joyful spirit
and pause and just feel it
how is this
it feels good
yes it feels
lighter
there's a certain unwinding
yes
sensation to it
beautiful so you're kind of
demonstrating in your own experience now
for other people who are listening
watching
you're really demonstrating what
meditation can do
it can open you from the
what's called the body of fear the small
sense of self
to of expansiveness and to a sense of
connection and well-being
and as you found a kind of adventure
and joy
now the beautiful thing is that even if
you're traveling and you happen to go to
costa rica or
you know
indonesia or wherever you go
that he's not far away
you can close your eyes
and he'll join you in spirit wherever
you are
because as in that circle he's part of
who you are
and it's always available
in five minutes
and this is one of the gifts of
of meditation and it's not like
pollyanna because there's a lot of
difficult things we have to
carry and mara keeps coming back with
aggression and doubt and so forth and
you can say yes i see you mara i know
you're here and there's the buddha
seating seated there saying yes i mara i
see you oh you're mara but that's not
who i am
thank you jack
oh it's a pleasure pleasure to
to sense you in this way because i know
it's true for you
you